Well, I think it's probably the same for any fantasy work, but after all,
Doctor Stone is set in Japan 3700 years in the future.
I think that's pretty much what I thought about at the very beginning.There is
this storyboard, and
the first thing you need to do to proceed with this cut is the setting, but it's the
character setting.
There are various stages, so
after
that, I'm doing things like showing the landscape, or rather, showing the overall view of the second place, so I'm doing things like drawing public characters and showing the backgrounds, but as
I just explained.  In
order to create this layout, the first thing we need is this
kind of
marriage.  I don't mean to say that it shouldn't work,
mother,
actually, after all, it's a dark seat.
Yes, everyone has been working on Dr. Stone since,
well, I want to add that greatness to it.The
selection of songs is in the main part.
I have to say, but
if it were the same, the director would definitely be deeply moved
[music]